[Música]
en nuestra sección de economía vamos a
analizar la noticia del momento en
Estados Unidos que es el discurso de la
unión que dará el presidente Joe biden
dentro de unas pocas horas Jorge Hurtado
bienvenido y cuéntenos que se espera que
diga el mandatario estadounidense en
este discurso en cuanto a la economía
Bueno lo principal se espera que biden
explique cómo piensa encarrilar la
economía estadounidense después de la
pandemia y también destaque los enormes
proyectos de ley sobre infraestructura e
inflación aprobados el año pasado una
encuesta muestra las principales
inquietudes de las sociedades
estadounidense y la mayor por supuesto
es la economía el 75% de la población
cree que la primera prioridad es
fortalecer la economía de ese país biden
repasará una lista de propuestas
económicas muchas de ellas con pocas
probabilidades de ser aprobadas por el
congreso entre ellas un impuesto mínimo
para los multimillonarios y la
cuadruplicación del impuesto sobre la
recompra de acciones por parte de las
empresas uno de sus principales logros
sin duda es la ley de reducción de la
inflación que incluye ayudas a empresas
que inviertan en tecnologías limpias
vigente desde el 1 de enero de este año
contempla subvenciones millonarias a
empresas que inviertan Precisamente en
Estados Unidos Este programa se
considera también atractivo para las
empresas europeas que se trasladan su
producción se verían favorecidas por los
precios de la energía en Estados Unidos
que son mucho más baratos que en Europa
Pero esto de alguna forma los ha
enfrentado con la Unión Europea pero los
ministros de economía de Francia Bruno
lemer y también de Alemania Robert Haven
dijeron tener garantías de sus
interlocutores estadounidenses de que
serán abordadas las preocupaciones
europeas sobre esta ley ya veremos
Entonces si se refiere o
no Además Jorge cambiemos de tema
dando nuevas versiones de sus motores de
búsqueda ante la victoria histórica de
Google bueno Bing y el navegador Edge
serán impulsados por la última
tecnología del fabricante del chat gpt
Open neirai de esta forma Microsoft
intenta ganar terreno al gigante de las
búsquedas de Google siendo el primero en
ofrecer una alternativa más
conversacional para encontrar respuestas
en la web y crear contenidos con el
anuncio la empresa está reinventando la
forma en que buscaríamos a partir de
ahora cualquier cosa en internet el
nuevo Bin que funciona con un modelo de
lenguaje más avanzado que el del chat
gpt puede activarse y desactivarse en
modo chat por su parte el nuevo
navegador incorpora el bim basado en
Inteligencia artificial para chatear y
escribir texto también puede resumir
páginas web y responder conversaciones o
conversacionalmente a todas las
consultas que uno tenga sobre las
búsquedas los anuncios de Microsoft y de
Google en las últimas semanas se
producen en medio de una repentina
atención la Inteligencia artificial
generativa que puede crear nuevos
contenidos a partir de texto fotos y
también arte increíble lo que puedo
hacer la inteligencia
artificial hablando de tecnología
esta aplicación para hacer
videoconferencias anunció despidos
masivos bueno en concreto despedirá a
1.300 personas esos aproximadamente el
15% de su planilla el presidente
ejecutivo de zoom Erick suyang reconoció
haber cometido errores al no evaluar
convenientemente el tamaño de sus
equipos para garantizar un crecimiento
sostenido zoom triplicó su tamaño en 24
meses los más críticos de la pandemia
mientras se convertía en una herramienta
de trabajo diaria para muchas de las
compañías que optaban por el teletrabajo
a los despedidos si estaban basados en
Estados Unidos zoom les va a garantizar
16 semanas de salario y cobertura médica
el pago de bonos anuales según su
rendimiento y también acceso prioritario
a acciones entre otros beneficios pero
zoom no es la única gigantes como Google
Microsoft Amazon y meta han despedido
personal en las últimas semanas en medio
de los temores globales por una
desaceleración económica y ante esa
desaceleración económica hoy habló el
presidente de la reserva Federal Estados
Unidos quien se refirió de nuevo a los
tipos de interés que dijo Bueno Paul
dice que será necesario continuar con
esta subidas de los tipos de interés
durante un tiempo ya que el proceso de
inflación que es lo contrario de la
inflación solo acaba de comenzar y tiene
un largo camino por recorrer el
presidente del Banco Central
estadounidense recordó que el objetivo
de la Fed es devolver la inflación al 2%
y que esto no será inmediato Aunque la
fe de espera que el 2023 sea un año de
caída significativas respecto a la
inflación ese objetivo podría llegar
hasta el año 2024 recientemente la Fed
anunció el octavo aumento consecutivo de
los tipos de interés de un cuarto de
punto que confirmó una ralentización en
las subidas aunque los datos del mercado
laboral estadounidense continúan sólidos
si se observa la oferta de trabajadores
frente a la demanda de trabajadores la
demanda de 5 millones mayor que la
oferta disponible algo que podría ser
repensar a la reserva Federal Al momento
de reducir el endurecimiento de la
política monetaria y cuál es la cifra
del día este siete de febrero bueno
tiene que ver con empleos economía
mexicana creó
111.699 empleos formales en el primer
mes del 2023 ese dato es el tercero
mayor aumento mensual en los últimos 16
años en ese país esto según el Instituto
Mexicano de seguro social buenas
noticias entonces para México Gracias
Jorge por toda la información económica
y nosotros continuamos con el debate